[Music]
i'm not proud of this and i'm sure many
of you can relate but i've been spending
a lot more time during this quarantine
on my phone on social media
and i've been reading a lot of the
comments it's very nice some of the
things people say but occasionally
obviously there are um you know you run
across a troll or two
a couple days ago maybe a couple weeks
ago now i ran into one where a guy just
said you dildo he called me a dildo
i was like you know i was sort of funny
actually uh and it didn't hurt my
feelings and then i saw another person
say that you dildo called me dildo
and they said big that then they
followed it up with something nice big
fan and i realized that they were
referencing uh this show i do called f
is for family i play a teenager we've
talked a little bit about it on the show
my character often uses that as a put
down as a pejorative well have you
considered the possibility that someone
might be a fan of f is for family and
thinks you're a dildo
oh no i hadn't well thanks yeah sure
anytime life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your dildoy host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always is my brother
uh not a dildo thank you some people
might think you're a dildo i'm sure some
people do it is kind of a good it's a
funny and it is
it's kind of unclear
what it means when you call someone to
dildo well it's like calling it i like
it's also a funny insult to a guy a
penis
that's more clear though yeah i think
you know what i mean
like when i when someone's like bill
o'reilly i think he's a penis well when
someone calls a guy a penis
it in my head at least it refers
it refers um to a pretty specific type
of person right like someone who's kind
of anal resistant yeah and yeah like
school yeah
yeah
whereas
dildo i feel like that insult is a
little foggy that's true it's more of
like it could be like a tool or a yes
yeah dildo and tool are interchangeable
i've said
what do you mean i'm a dildo like uh
like i'm a tool
um
yeah
so you're uh why about your hit netflix
show
by the way i'm in a couple netflix shows
that are the opposite of hits what do
you call an opposite uh bombs yeah
uh it's
very hodgy
cheery
yeah yeah it needs it it needs in that
jiri [ __ ] is this i really love it i i'm
proud to be in it um it's this bbc
netflix show it's on netflix so check it
out but also a show called episode
family that uh bill burr created with
vince vaughn and peter billingsley a
couple uh old pals
very funny show i think and um why are
we talking about this you're right guess
what else is on netflix what's that
tiger king i'm not familiar oh really
it's a show it's just let me guess let
me guess it's about a
uh
the leader of a pack of tigers who is
like the king in a sense of the tigers
or it's a remake of king arthur the king
arthur legend done by puppets of tigers
tiger park well you were a little closer
on the first guest oh okay you were
actually kind of right on the first gust
it is right yeah so for those who have
not much of a joke the tiger king on
netflix for like the 12 of you who
haven't
uh eight of whom are taliban members it
is a show about um
the feud between a man named joe exotic
and a woman named carol baskin
and um
very generally that's what it's about
it's about now the most famous baskin it
used to be baskin robbins todd baskin
from baskin robbins yeah
um fact check yeah i'm sure your real
name is i wonder baskin
isn't it baskin robbins isn't it robin's
last name oh i thought it was two
different people maybe maybe
jeffrey baskin and billy uh robbins oh
you know i just noticed that i i was
reminded that of uh hannah barbera
yesterday because chris and i were
watching oh this is a good quarantine
hack i hate that term life hack but
did that just give you douche chills no
no you were moving your head i was
cracking my back up uh we watched these
old um disney on disney plus now not an
ad but hey i also have a show on disney
plus go shop glasses
um but they have put their shorts on
disney plus old like shorts from the 40s
50s classic classics yeah there's one um
called bz bear so funny with a character
called um ranger brownstone what's your
impression of him
yesterday come on bears put it in the
bag take it out the bag
back to the show
um do you just know i want to do the
impression yeah i actually didn't i
wasn't setting myself oh really no
don't know you very well
but the voice created voice actor named
bill thompson what's your impression of
uh ranger brownstone put it in the blank
change you know again
oh he's not a friend
that character is a little bit like a he
you could call him a tool or a penis
no no not a dildo i'm sorry he's a penis
because he's very school mommy he's very
anal ridiculous he is he's always
chiding but he's he's
he's very round yeah and i tend to think
of penises
when
[Music]
most penises i know they tend to be um
like string beans who are very efficient
that's true he's shaped more like a cho
to this character so back to the tiger
king
before the tiger king
phenomenon on netflix phenomenon the um
that the nation is captivated by
before that we had it's like it's like
the national if there was a national
water cooler yes before that we had a
podcast on wondering not an ad
called it was originally called
over my dead body yes and now it's been
renamed to the tiger king joe exotic
it was a podcast hosted
and reported on by a man named robert
moore who is our guest today
uh much like and i and now they're
making a series uh which most of you
probably know that kate mckinnon is
going to play carol baskin they're
making a series of from that podcast
people i think maybe think it's from the
netflix series but it's not it's
actually based on the podcast that as
you said our guest robert moore is
responsible for so we're going to talk
to robert um about not just tiger king
related things uh but about
what he does for a living which is so
fascinating he's a journey he's been a
writer and journalist from for many
years and and a very talented one as
you'll as if you've heard the podcast
you already know this
so here coming up is my chat with
the tiger king
originator
robert moore
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
joe exotic is
maybe the zaniest character that i've
encountered how did you find him how did
you first become aware of him back in
2015 i was you know i just finished my
first book and i was casting about for
magazine articles to write i ran across
a story
in the la times it said michael
jackson's alligators burned alive in
animal park fire
and
you're like i'm listening
whoa yeah and so
that's just such an odd uh headline so i
click on it and then it talks about this
guy named joe exotic and and again and
didn't call him josh rival i called him
joe exotic and then i thought what kind
of name is that so i googled joe exotic
and then like everyone does i just fell
down the rabbit hole of
exotic
and back then there was no
you know there really wasn't a lot of
reporting on his feud with carol it was
just about there are a couple newspaper
stories about this quirky guy in
oklahoma so i i just thought i'll pitch
it to this magazine as like a profile of
an odd character living you know they're
breeding these ligers and thai ligers
and lilacers all these weird mutant cats
see i always thought liger's i thought
it was a myth right from napoleon
dynamite yes i know it's a real thing
and not only that then people assume if
it is a real thing well they're probably
sterile you know it's like a mule or
something but they're not you can you
can breed a tiger a liger with a tiger
or a lion and you can come up with a
thai liger or a lie liger and and joe
was one of the first people by his own
estimate was the first person ever to
breed a thai liger
and then he would sell them he sold a
pair of them to the uh to the crown
prince of dubai for like i think it was
like i can't remember now but something
like thirty thousand dollars you know
god how does somebody like joe exotic
even get in touch with the crown prince
of dubai like how do they find each
other
you know i i really don't know how the
crown prince of dubai found him there is
a definitely like an underground network
of exotic animal people who are all kind
of in touch with you yeah joe when you
were around joe he was fielding phone
calls constantly like constantly his his
cell phone was ringing constantly people
you spent a week with him
yeah yeah so that's so to pick that
story back up then i went down for this
magazine and i spent a week living at
joe zoo he gave me a trailer to live in
and i just followed him around like all
day every day for for five full days i
would imagine he loved the attention
right for sure i mean that's one of the
amazing things is that he would make
time for like any journalist even though
even if he felt like it was going to be
critical he would still do it because he
said all attention is good attention
he was a very strong believer in that i
wonder how he feels about all of this
now i mean talk about attention
nobody there are few people in the world
getting more attention now than joe
exotic i wonder if he's how aware of
that he is from behind bars and have you
had any contact with him
i haven't had any contact with him since
the podcast when people listen to the
podcast they'll hear our last episode
uh my last conversation that's right
they didn't want you all contentious
yeah yes yeah he was he was really angry
he basically said [ __ ] you rob i think
we're like some of the last words he
ever spoke to me but um wow
but the
the documentarians have been in touch
with him and of course he's been
fielding like interviews somehow through
from from prison sort of through email
and stuff and i think he is the word
i've gotten is he's he's over the moon
he's really excited that he's so famous
now
um he thinks that he's gonna be able to
parlay this into some kind of you know
he thinks he's gonna get uh a
presidential pardon from trump or
something you all this pressure will get
him out joe ran for president he was
inspired by trump he he did look at
trump and said like if he can do it why
can't i and and was you know was a big
like he he really
felt that trump was going to be this
great savior for the exotic animal world
oh right well because there was that act
that was uh in congress right that never
the big cats act that would have just
destroyed all the the
it still didn't pull up for it
it has never it's never come up for a
vote it's called the big cat public
safety act it can still
pass and and i don't really see it
splitting yet along partisan lines as
much as you would think i mean joe has
tried to make this argument that this is
like you know the right to bear arms
like if i can
afford to feed an elephant i should be
allowed to own an elephant is what he
wants to say the truth is and i wonder
how you feel about this the truth is he
is a pretty the things that this guy has
done are pretty despicable um yeah with
our podcast we tried to deal with joe
you were very neutral in the sense that
i think we looked at him with clear eyes
we looked at the case with clear eyes
and we said here's what's interesting
about joe here's what's compelling about
joe and here's what's despicable about
jesus yes yeah
i think that the documentary one of its
one of its failings is and i give the
the documentarians all the credit in the
world for the amount of work they put
into it and how how well they they were
able to shape this really messy
narrative into this really really
compelling entertaining package but yeah
i think they left people with the the
impression that joe is this kind of
underdog
hero and and and
innocent of that crime which is just
just not the case i mean
you know if you look at the the facts of
the case and you look at the facts of
joe's life like he did kind of turn into
a monster now i don't think that
anyone is
you know beyond redeeming and i am not
really a big supporter of you know
retributive justice i hope he can be
like restored and brought back to public
life as someone you know who's sort of
worked through all his issues but
to say free joe exotic and like to lift
him up as some kind of hero is just
grotesque in my opinion that was a clear
difference between um
what you did and the documentary and
it may be part of the documentary's
entertainment appeal um
that they
you know that they they've told this
story in such a way that it it does make
him out to be uh
almost heroic yeah i i in people yeah
people want to pull from and it's a
better in a way it's a better narrative
because yeah it's the last twist is oh
joe's actually the good guy and carol's
actually the bad guy and i've been
hearing people they keep when they're
interviewing me they keep saying are you
team joe or team carol and i'm like guys
this is real life this is not like the
hunger games or something well you know
again like these are people these are
real people they're competent yeah
what were your impressions of carol um
[Music]
you know you say they they created this
narrative do you think what do you think
about that narrative was was unfair in
terms of the carol
uh joe
dynamic when you're in carol's presence
you're dealing with someone who's really
intelligent and really careful you know
who's very shrewd and yeah and that
doesn't come across in the documentary
what comes across in the documentary is
that she's really wacky and kind of
spacey and there is a little bit of that
to her she has a tendency to laugh in
inappropriate moments and kind of like
look off in this way as if she's like
looking to the heavens and
yeah
that's not the deeper like truth of who
you experience when you're in her
presence you experienced someone who
left home when she was 15
and had to like struggle to stay alive
was hardened
slept under parked cars and wow you know
a rape survivor and and god knows what
to stay alive and made this thing for
herself and
the sense that you get is that she's uh
yeah that she's she's very very shrewd
and and
a little bit disingenuous i mean you do
get that sense at times that she's not
telling you the truth you know uh and i
think that comes across but what is the
fundamental difference between
carol keeping all of these big cats uh
behind bars and
yeah technically rescuing them but also
profiting from that rescue
and and joe doing what he does obviously
the breeding thing is a big thing
yeah so so i guess what what disturbs me
about that framing is that's joe's
framing that is like that's the way joe
expresses it and and to a certain extent
it's true if you go to her place and you
go to his place what are you seeing
you're seeing cats in cages and you're
and they're charging you money but
that's a really small part of the puzzle
because when you zoom out what carol's
doing she's not breeding these cats
she's not letting people pet them so
she's not like perpetuating this system
where these cats are are going to
continue just breeding and breeding and
breeding and being exploited and as she
would say exploited and you know kept in
cages in people's backyards and whatnot
whereas joe was breeding them like crazy
the other thing is that
people keep saying oh she gets so rich
off of it i looked at her tax records i
think she gets like sixty thousand
dollars a year from big cat rescue most
of her money comes from her like giant
empire of of like low rent real estate
um you know she does these these all
sorts of like
i think they're called quit claim
loans and it's very complicated uh sort
of real estate dealings where she buys
up people's underwater mortgages
now people want to look into that and
how she gets her money from that that i
think is is more fair but i don't think
that this idea that like she's
that she's you know uh
exploiting these cats to make money off
of them is necessarily true that's
really interesting because that was one
of the
key components of how i
felt about her and and the
hypocritical
nature of what she seems to be standing
for and doing um
because they make that pretty clear in
the documentary that
i think it was 1.5 i think she makes the
number they gave was like 1.5 million
dollars a year and they make it seem
like she's making that from
ticket sales at the park that's
interesting well no and they get yeah
they do have they do pull in millions of
dollars a year in donations and and you
know and ticket sales and things like
that but it's expensive to run yeah well
and it goes it goes towards the charity
i mean it's you know if you go on
charity navigator you can see they have
a very high score um you know so they've
been vetted to a certain degree by these
independent services which look through
their financials and show them like
they're they're they're doing that
they're raising that money in an attempt
to spread awareness and and pass this
legislation and all that and this guy
howard baskin who i also don't think the
documentary gives a fair hearing to you
know
carol's husband is a very smart guy he
went to harvard business school he's a
business degree from harvard he uh has a
law degree he is the person who kind of
professionalized that operation he's
also the one who is mostly pursuing joe
behind the scenes he was the one
pursuing those lawsuits he was the one
sort of putting out a lot of the
information online and um joe is
obsessed with carol you know for a
variety of reasons but the the irony it
was actually a lot of it was howard i
know there's a new netflix uh episode
coming up in the trailer that there was
a shot of him on a leash she's leading
him around on a leash and a little on
all fours uh do you have any idea what
their reference is just for my own
curiosity howard and carol were getting
married on a beach and howard for some
reason got it into his head it would be
funny
just before the wedding to take off his
suit and put on a caveman outfit
and so he comes down the beach in a full
caveman outfit with a club and like a
fake wig and everything
and carol starts laughing like what are
you doing and she i would you know she
put up with it and you know i i don't
think she was overjoyed about it but
they then they get married and they do
this series of photographs where
howard is like clubbing carol over the
head with the club and throwing her over
his shoulder and like walking off that's
funny and then the last series of
photographs is she puts him on a leash
and he's like crouching by her side oh
oh
lifelong bachelor i think he was i think
he was in his 40s when they were finally
married oh and it was his first marriage
and so the joke was you know lifelong
bachelor's oh
it doesn't seem like very howard it
doesn't seem like a very howard basket
thing to do you've seen the netflix so
you've obviously seen the netflix series
i've watched it yeah i'm wondering what
what is your what are your thoughts on
it
well i it's that's why it's it's really
interesting talking to you about someone
who knows the story that well because
i feel somewhat
not cheated because i was very
entertained by it but it's somewhat
short changed you know it's such
compelling material and it's and it's
told in such an entertaining way that
your curiosity is so peaked that you
just want to know you want the truth you
want to know of course i want to know
what happened now i'm invested
it's an interesting story because that
kind of is is
inevitable in some ways because the
story itself when you really boil it
down is not that interesting what makes
it interesting is
that all of the other stuff i describe
it as fractal weirdness you know like
it's like you can just zoom in and zoom
in and zoom in and every single detail
gets stranger and stranger and stranger
like it never stops and it's
all the ancillary characters too like
everything every single part of this
every thing in the background is is
strange as well and so
there's something really exciting about
that but you have to figure out a way to
tell a story and i so i think you know
again i don't totally um blame the
documentarians i think it
to some degree it's just a structural
challenge of trying to tell a story this
messy well that's interesting you say
about the fractal weirdness because my
general impression of it was
the mounting curiosity about it never
really paid off and i think that's to
your point i think it's because
as you said it's it's really just kind
of a not a boring story but a a simpler
story um
anti-climactic story it's very
anticlimactic so after so the last two
episodes after um maldonado killed
himself i uh
the characters that were revealed
weren't as as shocking because you kind
of at that point had met everybody and
all that fracked awareness had been
exposed already i guess um
and so then it's just like oh okay yeah
he hired somebody to do this awful thing
and now he's in prison i mean it's
impossible to pay that kind of rich
complex setup off entirely it's funny
isn't it it's a kind of a twisted thing
about the the true crime genre that like
the fact that someone was not murdered
is like disappointing to us
you know oh yeah maybe people are like
like that like as viewers people are
like oh
what a letdown no one was killed like
that's really grotesque and that's
really dark that's set up as art but
this is part of my my larger you know
sort of rant about all this is that no
one seems to be perceiving all of this
as real like they don't truly understand
that these are real
people and and they'll say things about
joe or about carol or about travis you
know or or john finley and i'm like
these are real people that you're
talking about these are not characters
in a tv show you know like i spent time
around these people i got to know travis
and you know like watching him sh you
know kill himself or at least watching
josh dial's reaction to it that was like
really painful for me yeah watching for
a lot of other people who knew travis
but to other people it's just shocking
expected or something it's a really
awful shocking thing but i can't imagine
what that must have been like to see it
and to have known gotten to know this
guy who
seemed like it's just a damaged um
kid i mean he was quite young
what were your impressions of him
of travis
yeah you know i i when i first got to
know him he was he was at the zoo there
was one day when we spent in joe's house
it was travis and a an adult film star
named rachel starr and the three of us
sat in it like joe's living room for
like three hours just playing with the
cats and talking and the sense i got
there was just he was he was just kind
of depressed and trapped you know he was
there he was smoking a lot of pot and i
asked him you know what do you want to
do like with your life you know he's in
his early 20s i'm like what do you what
are you gonna do and he said
[ __ ] it like he had no he had that and i
said [ __ ] it he said [ __ ] it like i like
like as if there was nothing there was
no future beyond the zoo
i later spent a bunch of time talking to
his mom you know cheryl who appears
briefly and this will maybe be
interesting too interesting to people
who you know want to see an inside
glimpse of how these things are made i
later spent like six hours in an
unheated motel room with her in oklahoma
just drinking black coffee and talking
about travis and herself and she was
just crying and crying and crying and
you know talking about her you know
she'd had a really rough time in life
struggles with addiction and she'd spent
time on the street and then travis had
grown up in these under these really
rough circumstances and all of that in
in the podcast ends up getting boiled
down to like you know one or two
sentences that she gets to say just
because they're so we we had to keep we
just had so many voices and there wasn't
enough room for her but
um you know that that to to get that
back story it makes a lot more sense how
travis ended up there he just you know
had a really rough upbringing and joe
offered him something he offered yeah
you know he offered a place to live and
guns and drugs and you know
like an escape some sort of escape but
then he became
trapped and i think that of of all of
joe's crimes i think that might be the
most
sinister of them that he
entrapped this i mean he held this kid
hostage in in a sense um yeah and and to
and to a greater degree than they even
let on in the documentary i i was told
by his sister that he he wasn't allowed
to communicate with his family he had to
message with her in a through a
messaging um app within a video game
because that was the only way he could
talk to her where joe wouldn't know
there was a time where travis left and
went to california and was like almost
gone and then he got pulled back in
and it's it's really really
quite sad it's heartbreaking
yeah having talked to travis's mother
for that long six hours how do you
how do you cull through that
conversation how do you boil that down
to
one or two sentences what's that process
like
you have to try to come up with a
structure that has some sense of like
narrative propulsion because if you slow
things down too much people will just
tune out and and you know and and that's
not really this isn't like
the cheryl maldonado podcast it's the
joe exotic you know and carol
story so you have to find ways that you
can fit that in in it and it feels
honestly it feels bad it feels bad to
like talk to someone for so long and
then they listen to the podcast and they
say that's all you got out of that but
that's just part of the experience and
also part of the work of being a
journalist is that you have to talk to
people for long amounts of time to gain
enough context so that when you do pull
those two sentences you're using them
accurately and honestly you're not sort
of pulling them out of context and using
them misleadingly it's like an iceberg
you know like 90 of the work of being a
journalist never goes above the surface
it's all just underneath
in the framing and that's where you
start to get the sense like i have this
you know huge knowledge encyclopedic
knowledge of the life of joe exotic and
carol baskin so i watch things like this
documentary or articles about it all i
see are like
the the ways that things have been
misleadingly framed or something i'm
feeling some guilt about my own role in
um
how i've dehumanized some of these
figures and treated them as though they
were
characters and i'm now thinking also
about the way america has been doing
that and now i i have misgivings about
you know adding to that attention and
and
how do you feel about the response that
the public response to a person like
this um and this story
i wouldn't have told this story if i
didn't feel there was some redeeming
quality to it i mean first of all
you know look america's trapped in their
houses they need something to entertain
them you know we're all yeah to some
degree we consider ourselves artists but
we're also in the business of
entertainment whether you're you know an
actor director writer journalist a
podcaster if something is boring people
won't engage with it i feel like with
the podcast we did a pretty good job of
telling an entertaining story story that
grips you and transports you and pulls
you out of your life for a little while
i think that has value now
journalistically i think as long as
we're remembering at the end of the day
that this is really about a you know
captive tiger ownership in america and
the way that thousands and thousands and
thousands of big cats are being kept in
cages and and bred and
i think that's some value and also i
think it's if there's a value in
plumbing the depths of someone like
joe's psychology is i feel like i was
paying more attention trying to pay more
attention to who is joe really and who
who is carol really and how does
something like this happen how what
leads people to make these decisions and
i think that there's a kind of deeper
truth that comes out of that that
hopefully enriches people and you know
it makes you realize that surreal things
happen every day in real life oh for
sure there's there's far more than just
i think salacious entertainment value in
that i think i think that's really um
worthwhile yeah i feel icky about it too
i feel icky about watching the
documentary
in the end of it there's there's a
feeling that you get where i'm like you
know have we been gawking at people's
misery and and their and their poverty
you know these lingering shots of john
finley's missing teeth you know that
that's something that we we really
agonized over with the podcast is i want
to make sure we're never making fun of
someone for having grown up poor you
know or having grown up without proper
dental care or without proper health
care or whatever it may be
there's actually one point in the
podcast where i feel like i felt really
bad because we described uh we described
john finley as having a rat tail a man
with a rat tail and a mouth full of
missing teeth john wrote to me said
that's really mean man like those my
teeth he's you know he's like i i my
teeth started falling out before i ever
met joe before i ever started doing meth
i didn't have good dental care when i
was growing up
so things like that start to
accrete with especially with this
documentary where you start to think is
part of the reason we're loving this so
much because we are laughing at these
people for being and the word i keep
seeing over and over again is white
trash you know it's like yeah that's a
really that's a really
gross thing if that's the reason people
are enjoying this so much i really hope
they interrogate that a little bit and
think harder about that impulse to to
laugh at people who have you know had
really hard lives
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
joe seems like he's very drawn to
you know male beauty did he ever
was he ever like flirty with you and did
it ever
get go there no actually never and and
that's that's an interesting thing i
don't know if i'm not his type if i'm a
little like too cut for him or something
but yeah so so at that time joe was also
really attracted to you know these
really these really rough very masculine
blueprints
guys you know there's there's a phrase
in the gay world that they say rough
trade you know like young straight or
straight acting guys who who yes sex
with older gay men you know for some
sort of financial arrangement yeah like
gay for pay they caught yeah nowadays
it's gay for pay exactly and and so um
i don't know he never or he just knew
that it would be a bad look to hit on a
journalist or or maybe i'm just not you
know i don't know
i'm not i'm no adonis i i didn't mean to
pick at an old wound no but it never
yeah it does sort of bother me that now
like one of my chopped liver
carol baskin but well it is odd because
he would he would sexually harass and
maybe this is part of it he would
sexually harass his employees ruthlessly
i mean and i watched it happen he would
if he had an attractive young man on his
staff
he would just hit on them and hit on the
hit on them and make jokes and make you
know off-color remarks until he
basically wore them down and there were
many more guys that are in the
documentary i mean he had my my account
at least four if not five husbands and a
lot of other guys who kind of went in
and out of there he called him his
puppies
he said
bringing these puppies for a day you
would play with them you know like
younger guys play with them for a night
or two and then let them go oh my god
and were they was he supplying them for
the most part with drug was that
in this rough trade situation yeah that
was definitely a part of it i know that
joe
uh yeah i mean he definitely was
supplying john finley with meth and he
was also giving him steroids which
really screwed john up he he started
having these roid rages he was
definitely giving travis a lot of a lot
of weed and occasionally giving him meth
as well i heard that one of his favorite
things to do
joe's was
to go rent a motel room this place
called the habana inn which is a sort of
like notorious gay cruising spot in
oklahoma city and they would rent a
motel room and just like for three or
four days just do meth and have orgies
like
with strangers like that was his sort of
way to unwind because life at the zoo
was very stressful and so he was he was
doing that fairly regularly
oh my god
i usually just take walks
[Laughter]
but you know to each his own um wow what
do you think of
i mean the the carol baskin elephant in
the room
what do you think of of her and her
husband and and
what are your thoughts on whether or not
she
did him in don lewis
it's really truly hard to say we looked
into it as deeply as we could um yeah
you know so so i went there with this
stack of documents that joe had given me
to interrogate carol so before i ever
met carol joe had filled my head with
all this information about carol you
know for the most part she had a fairly
consistent
explanation you know that she thinks don
was suffering from
like a kind of alzheimer's a sort of
dementia and had probably had been
planning
to at some point go down to costa rica
and had been flying his plane
over the gulf and crashed that's that's
her guess but then certain of her
answers didn't make sense like i said
why does the signature on this power of
attorney not match the signature on this
restraining order and she said oh well
don was basically illiterate so he
always signed his signature differently
each time
you know and i was like i don't think
that's right yeah the million-dollar
question is did carol do it and the
truth is we just don't
no and that's not because you know
partially i'm not going to go out here
and and accuse someone of murder you
know
who's never even named a suspect but
also we really don't know there there is
a very plausible chance that that dawn
just disappeared you know he just went
away
whether it was to costa rica or more
likely somewhere else because they
looked in costa rica and they couldn't
find him it's it's really an interesting
mystery and and hopefully we'll one day
get to the bottom of it you know
apparently tampa the tampa police have
been getting calls left and right with
tips and people i heard forward so
i heard i also heard none of them seemed
all that credible but maybe there are a
few no they said yeah they said they're
getting six tips a day and so far none
of them are credible but
um you know wouldn't you love to read
those
i'd love to hear them yeah
yeah uh i couldn't believe that
statistic um that that more tigers are
exist in captivity in america than do in
the wild like just that alone is uh yeah
it's just a horrifying statistic you
know it all comes down to power and they
use these animals it's like look i have
so much power over this powerful animal
i can walk with tigers that's what joe
would always say i i can walk with
tigers most people can't and they they
perceive it as a sign of their toughness
and their dominance and and that sort of
bleeds over into other people you know
that's how they're able to secure all
these like partners sure yeah and
employees and people who will devote
their lives to them because they think
they're like larger than life
it makes you wonder how if they're and
in what ways they're impotent in their
own lives you know how where they're if
they all have a similar damage which is
they feel
uh powerless or impotent in some ways
and and they want to uh
usurp some sort of power from these
animals and people i i can't speak to
jeff lowe because i didn't ask him
enough about his childhood but that is
certainly true
of joe i mean that's something that we
go into a good deal in the podcast and
and to an even greater extent in my new
york magazine stories is joe's a kid who
grew up you know not just just gay and
and being bullied and you know texas and
wyoming and kansas as they described in
the documentary he was also the victim
of of rape when he was five years old he
was sexually abused and
the world was was really hard to joe you
know it was not an easy place yeah it's
not easy being joe tribe vogel growing
up in centennial wyoming and so he
turned to animals he really did he you
know i heard stories i interviewed his
mom i interviewed lots of people in his
family and they said um that they that
he would take in these raccoons and take
in animals just that had been injured on
the side of the road and he always loved
animals and he discovered exotic animals
and started taking in birds and and he
started you know raising poodles he had
a pet store like the animals were in his
life his whole life
and maybe i identified in some way with
you know these misfit uh animals these
animals that were
had been neglected in some way i think
that's true yeah the really crass way
that joe would put it at the zoo is he
said we take all the retards
and and what he meant was uh that
that we take the animals that the big
zoos won't take because the big zoos
want animals that look pristine because
it depresses people to see an animal
with with crossed eyes or a missing limb
or something like that yeah and he would
take them all
and
you know there was when i first met joe
that sort of appealed to me i thought
wow this is the guy yeah yeah who has
this this underdog quality he takes in
employees that no one else will employ
you know he takes some people right out
of prison people with addiction issues
that is admirable and yet the deeper you
dig you realize that was all a facade he
was yes he was taking those animals but
he was also breeding them he was
breeding tons of them for more lives and
cages yes he was taking in employees
he was taking advantage of them yeah he
was paying him 150 a week right you know
they were living in these filthy
trailers he would uh lock them in at
night so they couldn't leave the park
if they tried to leave if they tried to
quit he would withhold their pay in
advance so they couldn't leave and then
he would i talked to multiple people who
said he would call the cops on them you
know and try and really destroy their
lives he was a very vindictive very very
controlling guy and that's where the
tigers you know so like you have this
guy who loves animals but then the
tigers are kind of a different thing
it's a different thing to love
your dog or your cat or even your your
cockatoo from loving a tiger there's a
very specific psychology of someone who
wants to have that big dangerous kind of
animal in your house that's why it's i
think really interesting to explore his
own childhood joe's own childhood and to
see him and his later behavior through
that
lens you know for a guy to grow up in a
repressed culture and being made fun of
and and abused i understand in a way the
instinct to flaunt
this lifestyle now i'm going to be in
your face i'm gonna be so
you know i'm gonna be outrageous about
it
yeah in that sense that that that's
another piece of the puzzle that was uh
that was left out of the documentary and
i was surprised by this is that before
joe had all these other husbands he had
a husband named brian rein and brian was
a guy that he'd met you know to gay bar
in dallas he was openly gay
uh and they had apparently like a nice
little life together they you know lived
in this this little trailer that joe was
had a pet store they raised poodles
together and then brian uh contracted
hiv and
essentially died in joe's arms in a
hospital parking lot and this is right
when joe had first opened the zoo he
first opened it was supposed to be a
sanctuary at that point right he was j
he wasn't buying or breeding animals at
that point he's just taking them in
and so brian dies in his arms
and and breaks his heart and this is
what person after person told me was
that joe changed after that the joe
tribe vogel that they had known who
loved animals and was kind of sweet and
vulnerable
started to disappear and this other
person joe exotic who was obsessed with
his ego and excessive power
started to emerge until by the end
there was no joke schreiberg left it was
all joe exotic that's a perfect example
of something that i wish hadn't been
left out of yeah the documentary and
that's fascinating having grown up gay
myself i'm keenly aware of the ways that
we protect ourselves end up warping us
right like the weight sort of you can
build up a lot of scar tissue and you
can think that that's armor you know and
eventually that scar tissue builds up so
much that you you're like restricted in
all these ways that contort you
and and i really think that's what
you're seeing when you look at joe
exotic a lot of people look at him and
they don't see a human being they see a
character they think that guy is like a
cartoon they can't believe it's real but
what you're looking at is emotional scar
tissue you're seeing a guy who's really
really damaged and had to project this
larger-than-life persona to protect
himself you know that was his armor it
was i mean he had this great story he
told me when he was in high school the
bullies were picking on him and so he
went around and sprinkled roofing nails
all over the parking lot of his high
school and he popped 100 cars tires
and they caught him for doing this and
they made him work all summer to pay off
the tires and i said joe you know was it
worth it and he said you know what it
was worth it because they never [ __ ]
with me again
i spent a lot of time trying to track
that down i went to joe's high school i
spoke with his old principal it turns
out that story's probably not true like
a lot of things joe says but it's really
revealing that he would tell that story
of what was essentially like a terrorist
act
and see himself as the hero right this
is me this is me this this is me
protecting myself and saying [ __ ] you to
the world if you don't like me and and
that's the way that he learned to deal
with people and that's was ultimately
his downfall
it's it's so well said what you said
about his scar to the emotional scar
tissue and how he is a product of
so much he's so scarred um the movie
writes uh that there's kate mckinnon i
think
uh bought did she buy the rights to the
movie well yeah so we signed a deal with
universal ucp they've signed it up for a
six episode or or some limited run mini
series it's very similar to what they
did with uh dirty john i don't know if
you saw dirty john oh yeah connie
britton and yeah and uh
so so it'll be similar to that and
they've cast kate mckinnon as carol
baskin she signed on for that so yeah
we're still looking around for someone
to play joe and i know that people are
stepping forward all the time it's a
it's a really um it's a really meaty
role you suggested margot robbie
where did that come from that was just a
that was just a moment of inspiration
you know because the first everyone's
first thought is oh david spade or or
something or um you know i've i've heard
some really good ones i heard sam
rockwell one one of them
yeah i thought that was a great
suggestion sam would be great um and uh
i love michael keaton
yes i can see that totally i can
definitely see michael keaton but i had
a moment where i was watching i tonya
and and it wasn't even
just that the the tone of that film i
think is similar to what the tone of the
joe exotic mini series will be that's
true but it was also it was her eyes her
eyes look just like joe's eyes and it
doesn't hurt that joe had tattooed
eyeliner on all the time but there's
something about the the spacing and the
size of her eyes and the intensity of
her eyes that just looks just like joe
and i thought it would be so perfect for
her to do like a switched albert knobs
type of
transformation you know oh right the
glenn close yeah exactly
yeah and she's an incredible actor uh
yeah that'd be cool to see i'm so
curious i mean yeah she would be
uh who who else do you i mean so you
would endorse the samurai casting i
would i would love that yeah i think he
would do a great job of it um you know
and i've heard other you know matthew
mcconaughey and people like that i don't
know i think that someone would would
have to be able to capture all of joe's
different resonances and his the layers
of his personality both his his
vulnerability and his sort of menace you
know and it's hard to get both of those
in one person yes um who can do all that
and
yeah weirdness i mean it's just
weirdness you've never seen a person
like joe you know you've just never seen
no well behave like that
well that's why my first thought was
christopher guest i thought oh god i
mean christopher guested a version of
him in uh i mean he's done versions of
that character but but uh
i i know the diabolical nature the
sinister nature and that
like we were talking about the damaged
sensitive vulnerable
side of him would be uh that's gonna be
challenging
gary oldman
gary oldman yeah
you also have to think it's someone who
should be able to play
joe throughout his life you know younger
joe older girl right um and in current
stage you know just very haggard current
day joe who who is really really
suffering in
in confinement you know in jail not in
prison um yeah the the other people
around him i heard you know that john
finley wants channing tatum to play uh
him which i thought was really good at
that
that's funny yeah
um yes
he's a little bit he's a little bit
bigger than than john is but um it's a
little flattering yeah it's sort of like
joe everybody brad pitt i heard how
exotic wanted brad pitt to play him
exactly yeah i heard that too joe joe
wants brad pitt which of course you know
everyone was brad pitt
i like that
you know during this crisis that we're
all experiencing in different ways but
in
very similar ways um
i like that this has been something that
everyone can kind of
talk about and distract themselves with
yeah
i think that uh i i think that there's
something going on with people
who are caught in in there's a really
interesting thing going with confinement
this idea that everyone's confined in
their homes and they're watching
on the one hand these characters these
people who seem so utterly unconfined
and unrestrained in their actions you
know who are like doing things none of
us would ever dream of doing and saying
things we never dreamed of doing that's
very cathartic but then there's also
this theme of confinement running
throughout the animals and right and
then by then there's joe in his cage and
i think that
people actually there's a certain amount
of transference going on where people
are identifying with joe
because they're stuck in their houses
all day and they're like this is
horrible imagine if i were trapped in a
jail in grady county oklahoma with no
windows you know oh my god
and i wonder if that plays into the
sense of like free the tiger king is
that's interesting people are
identifying with them more than
otherwise would
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello against your booming we'll
meet again
what is your most commonly used emoji
oh my most commonly used emoji um
it looks like it looks like number one
is the fire the fire emoji oh okay yeah
yeah i don't know why i don't think
that's maybe my most recent i feel like
i do a lot of uh
a lot of the one with the blush cheeks
and the big eyes that's sort of
expressing uh
both embarrassing and horror yes yes
yeah i like that one i'm often in that
state uh
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play you know it's
funny if i were a kid i would have told
you no question um that i wanted to be a
basketball player i loved you know i
grew up in
chicago it was just a huge
you know we we would meet like i met
john paxton and and you know steve kerr
and all those guys and
you only met the white players yeah
exactly i would have loved to be like a
short white guy shooting threes you know
yeah yeah that was my dream i would just
practice like threes all day in my in my
backyard in my driveway but i was never
any good um nowadays i think i probably
i guess maybe a professional tennis
player i love uh i love watching tennis
and i love um you know watching someone
as elegant as as federer and the way
he's managed to continue that career
unless i can choose being like a
professional rock climber or mountaineer
i don't know if you consider those
sports but yeah i don't think so yeah
who doesn't want to be alex honnold
that's pretty pretty oh my god i love
that movie and i can't wait for the uh
michael jordan documentary the um i
think it's the 30 for 30 i'm michael
jordan yeah if you could have one snack
food for the rest of your life what
would it be
i love a dried mango like a like a
trader joe's unsweetened yeah that dried
mango although you get a they're very
hit or miss like half of like half of
every like every package you get every
other one is garbage and the other one
is like the most delicious like fruit
roll-up
yeah i feel like that way about mangoes
in general and then my other one is i'm
a huge fan of mexican bodega snacks um
and there are these ones they they have
these peanuts that are like they're
called like japanese style japanese like
japanese style peanuts which have this
like coating on them and then they roll
those in chili and like have like fake
lime flavor on them
oh the most delicious thing they
probably have msg in them too but
they're so so addictive
those are the red ones i've seen those
sold at uh they're like kind of red on
the outside bright bright red yeah if
you could live uh somewhere else where
would it be besides british columbia ooh
like southern thailand is just an
amazing place to me because you've got
the ocean and you've got rock climbing
right there and just the pace of life
and the food yeah i would it's it's a
really magical place because it's just
the people like cool so slow and it's so
so beautiful
oh i'd love to go there um
besides the beach what's your favorite
movie of all time oh man i mean that's
such a hard one to say i know i know if
i had to choose or one you know a better
one for like these quarantine times
what's one that is uh like a comforting
one one that you found yourself wanting
to watch
just just to be comforted by i
definitely the thing i've been turning
to during the quarantine isn't a movie
it's it's the show adventure time have
you ever seen that the cartoon adventure
time it's like a just about a boy and
his dog who are best friends and go out
and have adventures but it's as if you
took all the surreal elements from the
simpsons and just made a show out of
that like all the hallucinatory moments
where the screen is like was that on
adult swim rob yes it was i think oh
okay i watch it on hulu but it's it each
episode is 11 minutes it's just this
delicious little like gummy worm of a
show that you just can't stop watching
and it's it's like totally comforting
yeah it's it's a it's a really really
good corn show
okay i'll check that out um uh if you
could have dinner with three people dead
or alive whom you've never met who would
who would they be
oh wow you know it's funny my first my
first impulse i spent a lot of time
studying buddhism so of course i think i
think of you know sakimuni like
siddhartha the the buddha but then he
didn't actually eat dinner he never ate
afternoon so he was just more for you
sitting there yeah watching me
yeah like judging you like the glutton
that i am exactly yeah um
well maybe go to the dinner having eaten
already so you're not
right
and then you know it would probably be a
a couple of
of my favorite writers you know who who
are you know i mean someone someone like
oscar wilde would be an incredible uh
dinner date you know the problem with
most writers is we're we're not very
good conversationalists we're actually
kind of in introspective and quiet and
awkward and ego driven so but i think
oscar wilde would be a a blast to talk
to you oh yeah and then yeah he might
monopolize the conversation though
that's true
but that's fine i'm okay with that
yeah yeah i i as long as i'm being
entertained um
the third one i think who would add
something wonderful to the to the
experience of having dinner together um
you know and all of our snacks or
something like that who just has yeah i
like that so far
it's a pretty weird dinner so far you
just got
awesome together
yeah i like the visual um rob who's your
favorite muppet do you have a favorite
muppet
oh uh i don't really it's been so long
since i watched the muppet you i think
as a kid i loved animal but but you know
who does oh yeah uh that's a great one
it's fitting for this as well i guess
yeah
yeah um if you could have uh
one super power what would it be
you know it's always it's always been a
toss-up for me between between flight
and and teleportation i think those are
like the the two obvious ones i i always
read comics as a kid like i was really
into x-men comics and obviously i think
that like all at the end of the day you
have to say that like what they call
telekinesis you know like the what jean
grey can do so removing objects with
your mind and
yeah is that's just hands down the best
superpower yeah i still catch myself i
don't know if you do this i catch myself
kind of like when something's just out
of reach just seeing if i could do it
you know just like just extending like a
little bit of a you know yeah luke
skywalker
yeah exactly like
i well i always wondered that about yoda
and
luke like would they do that with just
like mundane things like
if a can of soda were just out of their
reach um
and it wasn't a lightsaber that they
needed
you know yeah you've become so lazy so
fast i mean i guess that's the problem
with it that's so funny you're never
money a lazy jedi
just yeah just a kind of
chubby couch-bound jedi
yeah
that's funny
um if you could you i assume you're an
animal lover that certainly the way
you've talked about animals over the
course of this conversation
um
did you grow up with animals and was
that one of the things that
drew you to the story uh when i was a
kid i actually did have
a fair number of now i'm thinking back
and i i had reptiles i had like a pet
snake i had a pet chameleon
um my my mom would
they they would often die um you know
it's sort of
like in when i was away and then i would
i would come back and have this very sad
reunion but my mom was very brass tacks
about all of it and she one time took
one of my dead snakes and worked it into
a wreath like a christmas wreath that
she hung on the front door yeah she my
mom's a she's an artist and she she has
a very strange mind sometimes and so i
came home from school and my pet was
hanging from our front door like as a
decoration
and i said my oh my god yeah she she uh
she also on another occasion she my
sister left we had a bunch of birds in
these beautiful old like teak uh bird
cages by this window and my sister was
house-sitting she left all the windows
open at night and you know in chicago it
gets very cold at night so
the birds froze to death they're all
these finches
and my sister went off to college and
then a couple of months later she gets
this care package from my mom and she's
so excited you know she's a freshman in
college she yeah she opens up 12 dead
finches in a box that my mom had mailed
to her as a practical joke
uh
oh my and you can imagine my sister's
roommate being like what is going on oh
my god
i know god would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny
ooh
i mean i guess i'd rather be called this
is this is going to sound like the the
right answer but i'd rather be called
unattractive because
that's something you know i'm keenly
aware that that's that that you're
attracting this is something that fades
year by year and and right you know that
that it's if you pin your ego on your
looks you're just gonna
end up really really tragically
disappointed yeah
not many like paul newman's out there
although i'm also not that funny so i
don't know uh
i guess it's a problem
which age if you could pick one age for
the rest of your life what would you
pick oh that is such a that is such a
tough one i'm 35 right now and um this
is a pretty good age to be honest i feel
kind of like i'm at the height of my
powers there's there's also that thing
going on where you know
gay guys seem to like stay in their 20s
throughout their 30s like physically
because we don't have kids and we
exercise obsessively so
we um right we like we don't like that's
a good stereotype yeah we don't we don't
we don't we don't seem to age as quickly
as straight guys
yeah and it's and it's great i mean i i
love being 35 i mean i also love being
you know 27 22.
you know it's fun because you're
you know you're you have a lot of
interest on your own god you're stupid
it's just when i look back on how dumb i
was i know in my early 20s
just it's painful it's physically
painful all right yeah i agree not about
you but yeah about me you would if you
know which
okay well i'll take your word for which
golden girl do you most identify with
dorothy blanche rose or sophia
oh um
i'm probably
half
rose half
dorothy if that makes yeah maybe more of
a dorothy who has played a rose at
various points in my life
oh wait a minute i'm getting questions
from my friends to ask you uh
somebody said how many genital piercings
does joe
so so joe joe just has the one the one
prince albert uh if people want to
listen to the bonus episode we have with
john finley you can hear john describing
getting that prince albert john actually
got his first and you can describe the
moment where i hear uh
john tells me
that when he got his prince albert the
next morning when he woke up and got
morning wood he bled for a week
and oh you can hear me that's about my
reaction yeah you can hear me
you can hear me crying
to
to the core of my being
oh my god yeah also what a weird
pavlovian response then to have uh
when you get
you know yeah when you become i know
excited uh wow well well john conway i
hope that satisfies your curiosity uh my
friend sean and as my friend diane want
to know what's the deal with rick
kirkman who set the fire how many times
has joe been married oh she has a lot
how many times has joe been married uh
well let's just who do you think set the
fire um the one that killed michael how
you originally discovered the story yeah
so so that it's pretty clear at this
point that that joe
got someone to light that fire i don't
think he did it himself he was out of
town he was in i believe um somewhere at
a funeral at the time uh but he
you know so there's two pieces of
evidence that are pretty damning
one is that there's a taped recording
where jeff lowe uh is remember in the
documentary where jeff's punching the
filing cabinet
yes
he's saying you know you you you're
you're embezzling money and this and
so so in those recordings there's a
brief moment where he says why don't you
just burn it all down like you did the
alligator thing
and joe
doesn't say anything in response he
doesn't protest there's no indignation
he's just kind of like
yeah you know and so so that seems
pretty damning the other thing is in
that documentary there's that piece of
footage which is an incredible piece of
footage where they apparently have joe
speaking to his lawyer on tape where the
lawyer is is basically putting the idea
in his head to burn down the alligator
studio you know he's saying to him
so joe all of that footage is just in
that one place and joe's like uh-huh
he's like there's no other copies
anywhere else you see what i'm saying
just like uh-huh
and
it it that apparently is the you know
the moment where it it it occurs to joe
i mean clicks yeah that's a great piece
of footage it's a great phone yeah
um and uh other than this is a good
question other than sef staff rather
have you do your knowledge have other
staff members been injured
i know there have been minor injuries um
of various people
nothing too serious i think the person
who is most seriously injured was joe
there there was a tiger named chainsaw
that apparently they're trying to get
chainsaw out of i think it was out of
the back of a truck and chainsaw bit
joe's leg and broke a tooth off in his
leg this is what joe's this is how joe
tells it
and
so joe would have this wound for a long
time people ask him how he got it he
would say he had he had a chainsaw
accident
that was oh no it's not a total lie that
was his clever way of of not admitting
that the tiger had bit him yeah wow in
your opinion does joe we touched on this
earlier does joe really love the animals
that's a tough one to answer i know that
joe did love the animals at a certain
point right i know that early on joe
really genuinely loved the animals and
love is a word that they use a lot these
exotic animal people one of the things i
noticed is that they they don't call it
petting an animal they call it loving on
an animal i love i'm loving on this
tiger and and that was the theme of of
so many conversations joe had was these
animals love me and i love them back
but then i think that in the later years
you have to imagine that as he got more
and more and more of these animals they
started to feel like a burden you know
he had to feed all these tigers it was
always just an overwhelming amount of
chores and he always needed money
and
i don't know if he genuinely i think he
may have lost sight of his love of
animals there by the end because you
know he was shooting them in the head
just to make room in the cages for other
i don't think he'd do that to an animal
he loved
of course so um yeah
yeah well i've been
loving
on talking to you
i've been loving on your podcast um
it's called joe exotic the tiger king
um thank you so much rob i it's just so
interesting talking to you about it
thank you justin that was fun yeah
[Music]
wow that just happened that happened
that's your joe exotic yeah that's he's
a [ __ ]
audition for joe exotic here's your
chance oh he's my this one
who wants to who didn't feed the tigers
thanks for coming in next
that's not bad actually i mean he's a
little bit like
you know sometimes he'd get down like
this
is that too you know you know who i have
in mind it would be funny to play this
just popped in my head to play joe
exotic
again leslie jordan and outside the box
like margot robbie was outside the box
yes um amy sedaris oh my god isn't that
brilliant oh my god
i was drinking as you said that i almost
did like a
spit yes
wow that's a great idea
because amy is just sounded like maybe i
think and maybe that sounded like her
that sounds like amy's amy's characters
you know but um because amy has her
characters have
what joe exotic has which is going to be
hard to capture for an actor this this
unhinged quality
and a and an innocence like a like a
damaged shot will we talked about that
just now um
who do you who do you want to play joe
exotic
who would be your top pick if you were
casting director you're um
um deb aquila
oh shout out you know i think i think
sam would be great yeah sam can because
he's
i mean physically he could be a match
he's playing although he doesn't look
like him necessarily but he could look
like him i think enough to make it
believable and he's he's great with
comedy and drama and i think he'd find
the levels
um in the character yeah sam played a
similar sounding character in this jared
hess movie that is who did the broncos
gentlemen broncos thank you
uh and i remember he remember him
sending me photos of that uh you just
google sam and gentlemen broncos it is
so funny he wore it like a prince
valiant style
funny in that i know you like
christopher guest for it but i i think
one he's too old that's kind of what rob
alluded to that he you have to be able
to play him when he's younger he made a
very interesting point about the
popularity of
the tiger king in our country and he
said
it was because he in part because
people
can relate to joe exotic in that
um we're all quarantined now oh yeah and
we feel somewhat confined in our lives
that was interesting and he is in prison
being confined and it's
tigers who are being confined in cages
so that metaphor of confinement yeah and
the timing of this quarantine and the
popularity of the show there's there's
it's an interesting thing i would have
never i would never have considered that
neither would i have he talked about the
documentary and i i did you get the
sense from him that not that he had
animosity towards the documentary but
that he considered his
podcast
a more
oh yeah a fair neutral accurate
representation of the story compared to
the documentary that was interesting and
i and he made some really salient points
about that i agree nice job slipping the
word salient into this conversation is
it salient i say salient but you know
tomato tomato is it really
i i think you can say salient i say i
hope so shorties
[Laughter]
but he was saying that the documentary
was
not as
fair maybe as it could have been in that
to the documentarian's credit
it made it more compelling yeah exactly
that the two central figures of the um
story were
painted in a more even-handed way it
helped me construct my argument that um
the show was kind the netflix series was
kind of anticlimactic it kind of it
helped explain why also i got
from him that joe exotic
is
more devious and
kind of rotten
than he's portrayed whereas carol is not
as uh devious and
neurotic let's say as she's portrayed in
the netflix series he yeah that's just
more he seemed to be more
um impressed by her
and he thought that the way that she was
portrayed
was as this kind of aloof spacey weirdo
with it with a you know tiger print
clothing yeah in the in the more shrewd
than that right and the fact that her
husband
in actuality the one who's who had been
pursuing
legal the legal stuff with joe more than
she had been yes but they don't explain
that in the netherlands no they
definitely she's seen as like a weirdo
who probably killed her husband in the
netflix series and yeah and he was
unclear whether she did or not kill her
husband but but he's portrayed as more
of um he's kind of tagging along he's
the unwitting
partner of right vengeful
person exactly but according to rob he
is very bright when harvard yeah you
know business school he's the one
leading the charge when it comes to our
collective fascination with this story
the tiger king um i think a lot of it
may have to do we talked a little bit
about our being able to identify with
the confinement it's similarly
comforting
as uh a jerry springer epis episode or
one of those shows that like dr phil
where they
where they highlight
people who are are really on the fringe
and have real like clear issues and and
uh
it's almost like
you know you can indulge in the sense
that well while my life may be bad it's
nowhere near at least i'm not like them
exactly right exactly there's something
kind of smug about watching people like
and he touched on this too that's right
condescending about that where they're
see like john with the missing teeth
they're seen as like kind of white trash
yeah yeah and it's it's
it's kind of fun to
drive people like that and mock them and
that's part of the appeal of the show
it's come it's it brings a level of
comfort to people yeah which i think is
kind of disgusting
but i'm probably guilty of of
that that may have been an element of my
own enjoyment right that i have to
consider and i'm not just saying this
because he was our our guest and i i
really like him rob um but he i think
his podcast does far more to humanize
them and i like that he was sensitive to
that i like that he was compassionate to
that uh rather than
you know being somebody who holds them
up to be mocked and derided uh that he
recognized their humanity and their
struggle and and when we talk about
actors playing these characters i think
an important thing
to to consider is um finding
the humanity in them all and and not
playing them
from a from a like a mocking position
and looking down very easy for instance
to play joe exotic as like just a
hillbilly yeah you know the psychology
of people who own tigers and you guys
talked about this a bit
is really fascinating that
and they use different words than they
would use for other pets you know like
like
a lot of love on him yeah yeah weird
there's something about the the power
and the ferocity of these creatures yeah
that uh and the way that that people are
drawn to them and and also like you see
even on dating profiles you know that
you see a lot of people posing with
these big game animals there's something
about like
this dominance i i've never felt the
need to
uh have more power or dominance in my
own life
that sounds like i'm so powerful and
dominant but i'm not you've just
accepted your accepted what i have so
i've never um
had a real i've had zero desire to
get near a tiger or any big cat
i i don't
really
have a strong desire to get near most
cats little cats where there's a bobcat
in here i don't mind cats actually in
fact wow that's just for cats to dogs
really yeah
like maggie your christmas girlfriend
sent us a photo of uh in our
neighborhood there's like one of those
neighborhood groups where they
you know you can what's it called uh
neighborhood watch yeah on the internet
on facebook and um somebody had sent in
our neighborhood there's a little bobcat
roaming around cute what'd you think of
that like would you well i wouldn't want
a bobcat because they're dangerous but
my my friend had a had a cat that i
liked mr kitty uh
and i like that i like cats that are you
know what it is it's cats that are more
like dogs like cats that are friendly
yeah that come up to you and cats get a
bad rap i think a lot of cats
people assume that cats are like all
kind of like
uh
out for their own paws and they like
don't get off me
but i i when you encounter one that's
friendly they're great because they're
really cute and they're fun to pet
that's true i also read so much garfield
as a kid that i think i had that image
in my head that kind of thing
personality lazy yeah
and like shitty to odie like garfield
yeah garfield was a dick he was a
general he was really mean to normal
normal but normal is cute i identify as
a cute cat
right and normal got more attention
because he was cute and stuff and yeah i
always felt a little bad for garfield
because he was like the
you know heavy heavy stuff i don't want
to offend garfield if you get a friendly
cat it's hard to beat a friendly cat in
my opinion friendly dogs though are i
mean a friendly dog well because
friendly dogs are
are like too much for me sometimes yes
it's too much work and they need too
much and they're really aggressively
friendly
exactly whereas a friendly cat
is um
much easier to maintain some sort of
respectful distance between
we're different in this way i would much
rather friendly die because i like
rolling around with dogs and likes
here's the letter okay
this is from kerry subject is staying
positive during times of uncertainty hi
justin and christian greetings from
minneapolis minnesota my name is curie
i know please don't butcher it i won't
i'm sorry okay my name is carrie and i
abs i also love minneapolis i shot a
movie there called it's not called best
man down with my friend addison it was
and and tyler levine it was so [ __ ]
fun i think that accent is my favorite
accent yeah single handed oh yeah wow
my
favorite accent really i love that
accent oh better than like scottish or
irish oh geez i love scottish uh really
yep wow
liverpool
uh i like that because the beatles but i
think if i didn't know who the beatles
were i don't think i'd love a
liverpoodline accent
maybe not but the beatles do exist
uh but you got to see yesterday by the
way speaking of a world where the
beatles don't exist
okay what a great movie good quarantine
recommendation it's on hbo now not a net
is it hbo now or hbo go who cares go
okay go with the letter go go go go and
go with the letter okay all right
greetings from minneapolis my name is
carrie and i absolutely love your
podcast thank you carrie thank you and
look forward to it every week as much as
i enjoy the interview portion the intro
and recap at the end with both of you is
always a highlight ah our mother agrees
i'm extremely extremely grateful for the
fact that i have a job where i'm able to
work from home for the time being
however with our temporary new normal
i've tried to be intentional about
making sure i'm staying positive
throughout the day
like kevin bacon having upbeat playlists
at the ready is a great way to help oh
yeah it's a good idea of course
listening to podcasts are always a go-to
as i love to keep my brain active and
focused on things other than the news at
times confession i've gone back and
re-listened to a few of my favorite life
is short episodes once or twice as well
wow that is what a compliment especially
the very end of jennifer goodwin's
episode where justin is talking to the
kid about harry potter it's truly the
best
that kid was funny you know i have other
funny recordings of him uh on a plane i
sat next to the skin on a plane he was
so entertaining
another way has been being more
intentional with connecting with loved
ones yes same i will send out morning
check-in texts to see how everyone is
doing and it's been a great way and
simple way to support each other i'll
admit i do feel guilty that this is
probably something i should have been
doing long ago before everything else
happened but i'll give myself a pass on
that one i totally agree carrie i
thought the same thing my friends and i
also planned a video conference call
where one of us organized a trivia game
that we played which i would highly
recommend
we did that
thank you for all of the awesome work
your team puts into the podcast sending
lots of positive vibes your way that
everyone is staying safe and healthy
during this time thank you so much
carrie
best carrie that was really nice thank
you um and
i'm uh i i agree with her on all these
things that's a very minnesota email it
is just positive and positive yeah um
thoughtful you know i i i found that way
i was struck by how
positive and and friendly the people of
minnesota were when i when i shot there
because i had never been i
and i was coming straight from
another positive place from austin um
and i was coming from being
sicker than i think to this day i'd ever
been uh i was scared i was really scary
actually really high fever and
god if i got that now i would
just
um but i was so sick and i i went right
to
such a great place minneapolis can't
recommend going there enough what does
this sickness have to do with minnesota
ah you know when you're relieved to be
healthy again grateful that's part of
the reason you enjoyed it so much yes i
think so maybe you know when you're sick
like that you you it really like
highlights all of the things that you
take for granted right being able to
breathe
exactly that smell that is somewhat
analogous i would say to
uh being in quarantine making you
more appreciative of what uh
how good you have it when in life don't
know and we take things for granted and
i think what kerry is saying about being
mindful of that and checking in with
people and
i think there's something that's really
good advice because during this time
it is very easy i think to become
complacent and fall into this new
reality of like being inside all the
time
but i think it's good and healthy to
remind yourself
uh consistently that this isn't normal
and you should do things to kind of
check in with people and check in with
your surroundings as much as you can and
not you know sit around in your pajamas
all day i saw that i think i'm
a great source of positivity and um
affirmative things i saw that on kristen
bell's instagram i think it was about it
had to do with uh that this isn't it's
life isn't life has just changed it
doesn't mean it's not still
beautiful and there's so much beauty in
it uh i hate saying that while people i
know people are suffering right now but
if you are fortunate enough to stay
inside or even if you're working with
limitations uh it is such a good
reminder to um appreciate
you know things that maybe you took for
granted sure uh so we've been doing that
and to the point where uh i've been
watching birds lately
we live in an area we're so lucky to be
surrounded by so many beautiful birds
and i've been
watching them more nice tonight look out
the window even last night when we saw
that moon beautiful moon last night
whereas like in the past i would have
like glanced at it and like oh yeah
and now it's like i want to say god i
just need to get off my phone a little
bit more me too you both have to get off
your phone that's my goal so thanks for
writing in kerry and thank you thanks
for listening to this on your phone yes
exactly
and if you guys want to write in we love
hearing from you
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
and uh we really are entertained and
moved
by your letters and it's really nice to
get them and we love doing that it's
also yeah and if you also if you want to
ask us anything yes feel free and in the
meantime be safe and stay happy and
grateful
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by christian lawn and
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
miesh lance audio engineer is sergio
enriquez with executive producers
marshall louis and hernan lopez for who
wandery who also did the tiger king the
joe exotic podcast not what it's called
have a good week
[Music]
what would you do with the brain if you
had one what would you do with the brain
if you had one i'd wear the hours
why if i had a brain i could
i could wire away the almonds
according to him what he would do with
the brain
is so much dumber than what he would do
without a brain
which is like figure out a way to get
off the post and interact with this nice
girly mates
wait what are the things you'd while
away the hours confer with the flowers
why do you need a brain to do that
animals can do that right well
what would you do with the brain if you
had one good question
if i had a brain i could
i could while away in the oven
i'd while away the hours okay don't need
a brain to do that
confirm it with the flowers okay well
maybe you get into botany
maybe just doesn't know how to say that
you